Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today, Jefferson Morley, who is an author,
editor of the blog JFK Facts and editor of
the Deep State's website.
His next book is called Scorpions Dance, The
President, the Spymaster and Watergate Watergate,
rather.
It's great to have you on, Jefferson.
Thank you.
Speaker 4: Thanks for having me, David.
Speaker 1: So the presidents for some time
have opted not to release the so-called JFK
papers.
There was initially quite a long delay put
in place in terms of releasing them to the
public.
Donald Trump and Joe Biden have taken positions
on that that have led to significant speculation
about what may be in these files and these
papers.
There are a number of what we might colloquially
call conspiracy theories that exist around
the murder of JFK, as I'm sure you know, and
the issue of the files has only has only fed
that.
Talk to us about what do we know about these
files and what are the reasons, at least as
stated, as to they're being kept private?
Speaker 4: OK, thank you, David.
Let's step back and just look at what the
law says that it's a little complicated, so
it's worth explaining to understand how we
have gotten to this moment.
Yes.
In 1992, Oliver Stone released his movie JFK,
which was without A-list Hollywood cast, a
very smart screenplay, a very compelling piece
of cinema.
Portrayed Kennedy's assassination is the work
of a high level conspiracy.
This triggered outrage in Washington indignation
severe attacks on Oliver Stone, which continue
to this day, saying he had taken liberties
with the history and all of that.
Stone responded with a very effective response,
which is if the government isn't hiding anything,
why is it hiding so much?
And he pointed out that in 1992, nearly 30
years after the assassination of the president,
80 percent of the government's records on
the subject were entirely classified.
He put that in the trailer at the end of the
movie, and he said, If you're upset about
this, call your congressman.
And so that resulted in a flood of mail to
Capitol Hill and Congress actually did the
right thing.
They said, we're going to release all these
records to quell all this speculation.
And so they passed a very strong law called
the JFK Records Act.
It passed unanimously.
Imagine that David unanimously something that
would never happen in today's political environment,
but pretty much everybody across the political
spectrum agreed.
All JFK records should be made public.
And so the law created an independent board
to go and ask government agencies for their
records.
The board reviewed them and released them
publicly.
The agencies, the CIA, the FBI, the Pentagon,
they had the right to request the delay of
the release of certain materials based on
their concerns about national security, privacy
and all of that.
So that was a very effective law.
And in the 1990s, we got a huge batch of new
records about the JFK assassination, which
really changed.
Understanding deepened our understanding of
what exactly happened on November 22nd, 1963,
when President Kennedy was assassinated, and
these records illuminated a couple of things
that were not known before.
Just how much the CIA knew about Lee Harvey.
Gay propaganda operations around Oswald, both
before and after the assassination, so we
learned a lot from those materials.
After 25 years, all of everything was supposed
to be made public.
Congress wrote a sunset provision after 25
years.
The agencies have the right to delay release
of information, but they can't postpone it
forever.
And after 25 years, everything should be made
secret.
I mean, made public.
So 1992 you go forward.
Fast forward 25 years October 2017 The final
release of JFK records falls to Donald Trump.
Trump goes on Twitter and says all JFK files
have been released ahead of time.
Not surprisingly, that statement was false.
All the JFK records were not released and
they were not released ahead of time.
When the dust cleared and we figured out what
had happened, what would have happened was
Mike Pompeo, CIA director went to Trump and
said, We cannot possibly release all of these
records.
And Christopher Wray from this FBI said the
same thing.
And so they prevailed on Trump to continue
to delay the release of this material, which
by law was supposed to become public for another
four years.
So we have some idea what's in those records.
A lot of those records have been declassified,
maybe except for a word or a paragraph.
So we know something about what's in these
records.
Four years later, the decision falls to Joe
Biden.
Last month and on late on the night of October
22nd, Biden, the White House announced that
nothing would be released this year, the second
time that the deadline written into the law
approved unanimously by Congress for the second
time, the federal agencies blew the deadline.
Speaker 1: Right.
And there.
Oh, sorry, we kind of lost connection with
their very second guy,
Speaker 4: but all the records that remain
incorrect.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Jefferson, your connection kind of went in
and out there, your connection went in and
out there, and so we we got 99 percent of
what you said there.
Let let me sort of frame up my my next question
here.
The speculation, of course, is that the full
release unredacted of everything would it
would tell us the truth about the assassination
itself.
Where is more measured perspectives?
Ah, well, there's potentially stuff in these
documents related to, for example, Operation
Northwoods or other things that don't really
relate to the assassination itself.
What do you believe
Speaker 2: is
Speaker 1: still unknown, so to speak?
Speaker 4: Well, I think what we learned from
from the disclosures in the 1990s is that
the official story that some guy came out
of nowhere and shot the president for no reason.
That story's false.
Lee Harvey Oswald, the man accused of doing
the killing, was very, very well known at
the upper ranks of the CIA.
So in my perspective, some people say and
people, it's a it's a it's a plausible argument.
It's a fair argument that they're hiding all
of this stuff.
But there's nothing really important in there,
nothing really germane to the assassination
itself.
Right.
That's a plausible argument, but I don't believe
it for a couple of reasons.
OK, one.
If you look at how much was hidden before
now, the agencies lose the presumption of
innocence because they every step before this
secrecy has hidden highly significant information.
So to say the last round of secrecy does not
involve highly significant information.
Of course, it's possible.
I haven't seen the records.
But based on the past history, I don't think
that that's warranted.
OK, the second thing is is that these records
could I'm not I'm not going to say they're
going to rearrange our understanding of the
assassination.
People have deeply felt beliefs about the
assassination and may not change their mind,
no matter what the evidence.
But I think that there is evidence that will
change decisively clarify.
I guess I would put it that way.
So for example, what do I think is in there?
I think.
Is an shows that a certain group of CIA officers
targeted Lee Harvey Oswald for operational
purposes before the assassination.
And if that's true, that could well be part
of a conspiracy to kill the president.
So I think that will will the will it show,
you know what happened in Dealey Plaza?
These records will not shed new light on what
happened in Dealey Plaza.
What they will shed new light on is what the
CIA knew about the the accused assassin and
the circumstances of the assassination before
and after Kennedy was killed.
That's where we see evidence of malfeasance
or misconduct.
And that's what these records could decisively
show.
OK, so let's let's
Speaker 1: explore that a little bit less.
It's OK.
So one very black and white story that some
tell is the CIA ran an operation directed
Lee Harvey Oswald to assassinate John F. Kennedy.
OK, that's one story.
What you're suggesting seems to be it could
be that Lee Harvey Oswald was not only known
to the CIA, but was actually previously used
by the CIA in certain operations not having
to do with the assassination.
Maybe the CIA even was aware that Lee Harvey
Oswald maybe wanted to kill the I'm sort of
just speculating here, and maybe the CIA didn't
stop him or something, but you're not necessarily
saying it's a directed assassination.
Speaker 4: Well, I haven't seen the records.
No, I understand, I understand, yeah, what
what you're saying is possible that that what
they're hiding is they're hiding incompetence.
You're not hiding incriminating information,
right?
I think that's possible.
Again, I doubt it because first of all, first
of all.
Even if that was the feeling inside the CIA,
like, oh, you know, we screwed up, we missed
this guy, we should have, you know, we could
have.
You might see some trace of that mentality
in the records.
OK.
There is nothing.
There is no evidence to confirm that in the
available record that that's why they are
doing what they are doing.
So that's one reason why I doubt it.
Nobody in the CIA has ever said, Oh, we screwed
up about Oswald.
If you look at their behavior, it is much
more consistent with this guy is part of a
covert operation that we cannot talk about.
And so what I'm saying is I think there's
an undisclosed CIA operation around Oswald,
whose purposes we don't know and whose purposes
the CIA does not want to disclose from there,
if that's true.
We will have a better understanding of how
to assess the conspiracy question.
Speaker 1: Let's pause our conversation there
with Jefferson Morley.
Full interview will be on YouTube.
We'll take a quick break
and be right back.